[Music]  Selena Gomez's mom  Mandy TV still not happy about her  daughter's relationship with Justin  Bieber mama don't but she's all about  moving forward a source tells ET Selena  knows how her mom feels about the  purpose singer quote Mandy has said her  piece they just don't talk about it  Mandy knows that Selena is an adult and  she's going to do what she wants in a  recent interview with gossip cop  Mandy expressed her displeasure with  Justin whom she says she hasn't spoken  to or texted in years Selena rekindled  her romance with Justin back in October  after she split from then-boyfriend  the weekend ET source believes the  reason TV it doesn't like Bieber is  because she thinks he was a terrible  influence and their past relationship  was toxic and took Gomez many years to  get over  [Music]